cos'è cos'è
allora cos'è io non l'ho visto mai
sembra un sol sembra un sogno sembra un
sogno
attendo jack ma cos'è cos'è la
complessità nel business e sempre
gestita con due principi fondamentali
del management hard e soft hard che pia
i biglietti vi flussi processi linea
tratteggiata linee continua e colorata
cerchi quadrati rettangoli soft
sensibilità relazioni sensazioni
negli ultimi otto anni ho percorso più
di un milione di chilometri io ho avuto
la fortuna di incontrare più di 5mila
persone
ho ascoltato le loro storie
ho condiviso momenti ho condiviso
esperienze con loro
mi sono accorto quando gestivano la
complessità lavoravano con me un impegno
inserirono nuovi responsabili noi middle
manager nuovi commissioni noi comitati e
questo poco impegno portare persone
addirittura ad essere dei motivate e ora
quando
ricordo cos'è la motivazione per me
ricordo i miei quattro anni ero alto più
o meno così riccio completamente diverso
era una roba pazzesca è un anno pazzesco
per me i miei quattro anni qualcosa di
atomico e andavo in giro e sentivo di
avere un mantello trasparente pieno di
superpoteri nessuno lo vedremo ma io li
sentivo tutti quei superpoteri mio
fratello mattia aveva sei anni più di me
anche ora siano in più di me però
all'epoca voleva dire che facevamo il
gioco bello il gioco bello era che lui
mi presentava al mondo e mi presentava
il mondo ogni giorno mi presentavo
qualcosa di nuovo e io la toccavo la
annusavo osservavo e la mangiavo magari
come quel mattino di maggio e romo a
positano e li corre da mi corre da me
jacopo jacopo giacomo guarda qui cosa mi
mostra una lumaca di mare che mangia in
da quel momento abbiamo avuto un
rapporto diversi e le lumache avuto
porto più confidenziale
non li ho mangiato e più mattia mi ha
continuato a dare fiducia e quindi mi ha
presentato i ricci mi ha presentato i
granchi e quei momenti diventavano per
me magia una magia che vi goss chi
definisce zona di sviluppo prossimale
non era la prima volta che vivevo quella
magia
già l'avevo vista vissuta
incrociando quello sguardo il primo
sguardo quello della donna che mi ha
amato prima ancora di incontrarmi mamma
e ancora con il mio primo team che li
presento rino grazia in avanti c'era
mario al centro mattia ed aura e importa
jacopo è con loro che ho compreso che
per fare un tavolo ci vuole il legno per
fare il team ci vuole fiducia per creare
una relazione di fiducia è necessaria
una comunicazione assertiva e necessaria
intelligenza emotiva e se lavoriamo
sulla base di una zona di sviluppo
prossimale facciamo sì che ogni membro
del team arricchisce le proprie
competenze hard soft creatività
flessibilità
ricordo quando avevo 8 anni addizionato
uno più uno
eravamo io e luca eravamo in quella che
è la villa comunale di fisciano immersa
nel verde
pensavamo fosse una foresta per noi in
realtà c'erano solo pochi alberi ma
dietro un cespuglio all'ombra di questo
studio ci nascondiamo e siamo protetti
nella nostra immaginazione
iniziamo ad immaginare un jetpack a
fotosintesi clorofilliana il giorno dopo
dicono dicono di averci trovato in
garage o smontare la sua peg perego
volendo da trasformare nel jet pecca
fotosintesi clorofilliana per il momento
preferiamo non ricordare luca oggi è qui
a 25 anni e questa fiducia ce l'ha
rinnoviamo ogni giorno quella che è
accaduto con luca è una zona di sviluppo
prossimale perché luca avevamo uno
scambio fluido le nostre risorse si sono
moltiplicate le nostre competenze sono
cresciute contemporaneamente in questi
anni ho scoperto azienda top azienda
personaggio persona che le aziende hanno
delle le credenze
una su tutte è quella che se tu lavori
tanto lavori duro raggiunge il successo
è se raggiunge il successo
raggiungi la felicità questa concezione
è alla base dei manager dei genitori è
quella che motiva i comportamenti
quello che so è che dopo
ci sono questi manager le aziende hanno
una produzione insoddisfacente anche se
i progressi tecnologici
ok anno la produzione insoddisfacente
le persone non sono realmente coinvolte
e il motivo ce lo dice la scienza la
comunità scientifica dice se ogni volta
che raggiunge un risultato il limite che
definisce il successo si sposta più in
avanti e quindi nella concezione
precedente dovremmo avere la felicità è
raggiungibile all'infinito sempre a
rincorrere da sempre a rincorrerla è
sempre la comunità scientifica ci
ricorda che se nutriamo di positività e
felicità e il nostro corpo il nostro
cervello lavora meglio ha più energia e
più creativo lavoro in modo più
intelligente la dopamina che va in
circolo quando siamo felici attiva tutte
le aree di apprendimento e con queste
aree di apprendimento che noi va
richiamo a nuove sfide con nuovi modi di
sfide in futuro ne avremo tante si spera
ci tengono giorni ci tengono vive una
delle grandi sfide e grandi domande che
abbiamo nei prossimi anni che sento
sempre più spesso è quali saranno i
lavori di domani ma il sacerdote
esisterà nel 2000 e 93
il sindaco esisterà nel 2050 e il medico
nel 2065 ora non sappiamo bene job title
i titoli di lavoro di queste persone ma
abbiamo delle certezze abbiamo la
certezza che oggi e domani ci troveremo
sempre più a valicare confine in modo
veloce e dovremmo prendere sempre più
scelto in modo lungimirante e per farlo
abbiamo sì bisogno di entusiasmo e oggi
ma la possibilità di liberare
quell'entusiasmo di prendere quel
mantello pieno di superpoteri e farlo
volare
abbiamo bisogno sì di esperienza e
competenza ma abbiamo bisogno di persone
con una salda struttura emotiva proprio
per questo nel 2016
abbiamo cofondato your digital abbiamo
pensato di connettere i talenti della
digital economy con le aziende in fase
di digital trasformation abbiamo pensato
che gli amministratori delegati potevano
aver bisogno di un partner nel processo
di evoluzione persone si con esperienza
persone si con con entusiasmo persone
con dieci piani di esperienza ed energia
che vanno lì fianco a fianco portando
management in missioni impossibili con i
16 c'è qualcosa di difficile ci siamo
l'uomo è nato per questo per superare i
limiti e avremo sempre più bisogno di
persone così
il presidente di lego group afferma che
il fallimento non è la colpa non è il
male
lui dice che la colpa è nel non dare
aiuto nel non chiedere aiuto e quindi
come con mio fratello che mi mostrava la
lumaca come con luca con lo scambio di
feedback continuo degli richiesta di
aiuto e di dare aiuto ho chiesto aiuto
quando sono stato chiamato a condividere
un pensiero su due più due uguale 5 alta
ed hicks di potenza ho chiesto aiuto ai
miei amici ho chiesto aiuto a mia nipote
emma e subito c'è comparso un numero 9.6
9.6 è il dato che esce fuori dal nostro
strumento di people analytics 2.6 è il
numero che rappresenta il livello di
crescita delle persone all'interno del
nostro gruppo dice mai chiesti perché le
persone del nostro gruppo crescono di
9.6 su dieci abbiamo capito che il
motivo è perché quando una persona entra
all'interno del gruppo partecipa dando
iniziando a donare facendo un gesto che
gli americani chiamano the first dando a
chi è più nuovo dando a chi ha meno
esperienza dando chi a chi chiede aiuto
in quel momento
ed è così che con la persona che riceve
non vede l'ora di restituire quella
fiducia il modo più veloce possibile
quando parliamo di complessità è sempre
qualcosa di divertente e noi abbiamo
cercato di semplificare l'approccio
utilizziamo un approccio che si basa su
due fattori per gestire la complessità
bisogna conoscere bene cosa fanno gli
altri
per gestire la complessità bisogna
rafforzare i punti di congiunzione la
forza dei punti di congiunzione non vuol
dire aggiungere una persona in più vuol
dire rafforzare chi già è punto di
congiunzione abilitarlo al feedback
continuo a quello scambio fluido e così
che si crea quella magia che è fiducia e
rispetto è qualcosa di delicatissimo che
non si sa mai
si perde
ho chiesto consiglio ad emma emma 8 anni
ed emma ha iniziato a spiegarmi cose
molto complesse io avevo difficoltà a
seguire la detto ok jacopo che ti faccio
un disegnino ringrazio tema per averci
spiegato due più due fa cinque grazie
[Applauso]